grasset et puis et puis alors un citoyen
belge hergé le père de tintin le père de
tintin en effet il y a il y aura
exactement 50 ans dans cinq jours le 10
janvier 1929 en effet paraissait pour la
première fois les aventures de tintin
tintin au pays des soviets dans un
journal illustré pour les enfants
catholiques is a tué le petit vingtième
je crois comment alors est-ce que donc
dans cinq jours ce sera cet anniversaire
est ce que est ce que le 10 janvier 1929
vous avez eu conscience et le 11 ou le
12 les consciences du succès on présente
pas du tout pas du tout du tout du tout
c'était vraiment je considérais sac une
petite farce comme besoin de choses sans
lendemain pour promulguer des amis
c'était c'était pas plus que ça c'était
pas autre chose que c est pourtant le
succès venu rapidement que oui mais un
petit succès dans un petit public non
c'était un journal catholique c'était le
20e siècle joindre confessionnelles donc
dont le tirage devait être aux alentours
de dix mille exemplaires par jour je ne
sais pas vous mais le lait tout gros
tirages et il ya eu un gros succès oui
mais parmi un tout petit public
oui mais pourtant on raconte que à la
fin de de tintin au pays des soviets
quentin revient donc à bruxelles est
accueilli en triomphe
oui oui enfin voila c'était un petit
triomphe ou particuliers pour déranger
les gens dans une guerre et oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai vous croyez moi on
organise ces nourrissons jamais dérangé
personne en matière jamais on est de
zéro c'est donc comme en question qu'on
a souvent ils vous poser mais cet
anniversaire du logis de la pause et
aussi à mon tour comment vous est venue
l'idée de ce personnage au fond quelles
sont les influences qui vous ont amené à
créer ce personnage de tintin le
reporter de 15 ans je crois que j'ai
toujours eu envie de raconter des
histoires et je les raconte est souvent
c'est pour ne pas les oublier les
illustrer quand j'étais déjà très très
très jeune
et puis après lorsqu'on m'a confié la
rédaction de ce petit supplément
illustré le petit vingtième parce que
d'un supplément de ce journal
2e siècle j'ai donc pensé à faire une
histoire d'un petit bonhomme mais comme
je savais très mal décider s'il est très
très très mal et que je me disais que ça
allait tout même duré quelques semaines
j'ai je me suis contenté de faire un
petit rond à cercle petite mèche pour
donner un accent comme ça j'étais
certain que ce personnage dont le
reconnaîtrai de dessin en dessin et de
semaine en semaine
c'est vrai que le premier tintin qu'on
trouve dans le pays des soviets et on va
nous le montrer tout à fait différent de
tintin qui est devenu célèbre par le
croquis oui mais pourquoi alors cessé
tout pète je pense être plus de
programmes en axant pour pour qu'ils ne
soient pas tout à fait rond sinon il
aurait un cercle ça n'était pas
tellement reconnaissable 6 enfin il
fallait un petit accent à ça j'ai donné
mais où et pourquoi alors qu'il suit
milou pourquoi un chien que parce qu'il
est pas bon que l'on soit seul il faut
voyager avec pour voyager je crois qu'un
chien est encore la meilleure hannibal
faisait difficilement de voyager avec
nous avec un téléphone avec un chat
difficile alors à chiens il y avait un
journal qui s'appelait ric et rac wurz
est nécessaire et le petit chien c'est
un espèce de fox terrier comme ça mais
qui est il de vous en train de vous deux
de ce que vous êtes de ce que vous
auriez aimé mais je crois que qu'il
s'agisse de romans ou qu'ils s'agissent
de théâtre mais je crois que tout auteur
quel qu'il soit y compris un auteur de
bande dessinée se met lui-même se
projette sur ses personnages et je crois
que tu atteins c'est une partie de moi
même j'aurais voulu être un héros car
elle voulait être un reporter comme vous
simplement commencer et puis c'est le
capitaine haddock avec mes colères mais
connaît vous êtes aussi au canada
oui je suis tout ça je crois que vous
faisait de la castafiore aussi oui
parfois parfois ça vous auriez vous le
modèle de l'opéra comique on en informe
enfin non mais les principaux
personnages
je me retrouve en parfois je crois que
c'est vrai je crois que dupont c'est moi
oh oui aussi oui je comme étant presque
de bêtise ça m'arrive de faire des
bêtises
alors oui oui moi ce qui me frappe en
regardant les l'analyste des titres des
aventures de tintin c'est que c'est le
côté c'est le côté au fond grand grand
littérateurs parce que vous avez fait
votre voyage en urcisse us si je ne m'en
mêle pas dans les dates avant gide les
relais vtt le voyage vous avez fait
votre voyage au congo avant lui aussi
ensuite vous avez fait votre chine
juste avant ou juste après malraux en
tout cas juste après la célèbre émission
est jeune il y à il y a une espèce de
similitudes entre les grandes démarche
comme ça des grands intellectuels des
grands écrivains français de langue
française et les petites aventures de
tintin
ils précèdent toujours les grands
écrivains et j'ai pressé dwi les
accompagnants fait en tout cas il est
dans l'air du temps exactement que c'est
cela ça c'est la nostalgie c'est la
nostalgie dur dur portable
évidemment sur la journée dans un
journal et pour moi leur héros c'était
l'europe est en train et tina reporter
voit au début il a pris la plume et
écrit un article
oui mais vous avez conduit la paix
reporter oui nous apparaît plutôt comme
un boy scout redresseur de torts vous et
comme un policier qui veut rétablir
l'ordre aux quatre coins du monde mais
pour nom la venturi vient de chercher à
domicile plutôt une part pas ça manque
on trouve enfin et après
il veut mettre de l'or au fond il met de
l'ordre partout où il passe tintin et
laurier il est d'ailleurs et j'ai
remarqué plusieurs fois en relisant les
tintin qui avait fait le bonheur de la
jeunesse
plusieurs fois des personnages sont des
méchants lui dise lorsqu'il est lié qui
va être exécuté jamais suivi chaque
forte
là vous avez la fâcheuse habitude tintin
de vous mêler de ce qui ne vous regarde
pas ils ont raison c'est je ne
présenterai ce que regardent pas tout à
fait raison mais au départ l'aventuré
vient me chercher à domicile
au départ ce n'est pas lui qu'il se
jette sous faulx débuts au début par
vraiment comment reporter il va vers les
points chauds du globe qui sont la
russie à l'époque pour l'amérique et la
chine et c'est comme vous avez dit alors
là il se mêle de choses qui le regarde
puisque cette à reporter qu'est-ce qu'il
a des défauts d'un mais ce sont les
autres ils en ont pour lui je crois
malheureusement pas il n'a que des
qualités n'a que des qualités sa
politique
mais même milou lui a déjà des défauts
parce que bilou j'ai remarqué il est il
est gourmand
oui il a peur alors que tintin n'a
jamais peur il a perdu des chats d'autre
part il est parfois même je suis le plus
creusé en tintin au tibet il emporta
mieux alors oui et ils préférent
boulanger l'a ouverte à d'autres en plus
en chopant ça me choque un peu le sens
je pense à mes laura deux camps revanche
une imprimante que des défauts parce
qu'il est coléreux je n'ai chiron
abdominale à propos du figaro magazine a
eu la très bonne idée d'en faire le
recensement il est ce qu'ils sont très
connus tonnerre de brest
bachi bouzouk e marins d'eau douce
quelques 5 soit s'étonnant par espèce de
fait math prisunic espèce de loup garou
à la grèce de renoncules également
savourer et celui là crétin des alpes où
il ya des crétins c'est la traduction
belge du bois du valais natal et oui
mais ça c'est un phénomène est logique
et et adopte enfin c'est un ivrogne de
commandes était au début leur teinte a
une mauvaise influence sur lui une
affluence remarquable et le capitaine
haddock en continu avant de temps en
temps envie ce qui n'est pas le seul et
est même plus tellement certain qu'il a
changé en fait on l'a remis dans le
droit chemin voit boire à la bouteille
par aucun pays n'a jamais protesté
contre le fait qu'un des personnages de
tintin et si les états unis n'étaient
pas permises
c'était pas pérenne vous avez été
censuré oui j'ai été censuré du temps de
la prohibition
oui non après après après on pouvait
boire chacun sait qu on pourrait très
très peu au numérique et on peut voir un
petit peu mais une fois pas montré qu'on
avait du plaisir et un taille haie de
gauche ou de droite
au début quand même de droite non au oui
sûrement
sûrement sûrement c'est de repartir d'un
journal catholique n'oubliez pas c'est
un journal donc le xxème siècle qui
était
non seulement confessionnel mais aussi
je crois de directeur était un ami
personnel de mussolini c'est vous dire
la tendance est toute façon c'était
c'était à ce moment là c'était pas la
russie soviétique c'était les bolcheviks
de l'homme au couteau entre les dents
c'était une atrocité c'était les
brisures de cloche enfin pour massacrer
des familles entières seydoux le premier
tintin au pays des voies la voie de
droite et est ce que enfin après il
devient alors anticolonialiste
ils deviennent petit à petit les volumes
ont l'apparence une évolution alors
entre eux les 50 ans entre tintin au
pays des soviets
et puis le dernier tintin chez les
picaros il ya 48 ans bon qu'elles sont
en quoi tintin changé physiquement ne
change pas si trading si il a des
pantalons longueur le changement mais
c'est vrai un gros changement mais ces
changements là pour concerne son moral
sont c'est très difficile à dire il ya
toujours gresser de thor c'est vrai mais
je crois qu'il est une voie moins le
monde en noir et blanc quand même il ya
les méchants ne sont pas tout à fait
méchants et les bombes sont plus tout à
fait nouveau c'est un peu ça parce que
des détails le lotus bleu oui en chine
on le voit et il
il intervient dans une bagarre où il ya
un affreux bonhomme blanche procès
un coulis et dans la défense et innovant
et puis même si les moralistes un moment
jeu il dit à un petit chinois qui la lui
dit mais non ne change tous les blancs
ne sont pas mauvais mais les peuples se
connaissent mal ça oui ça c'était là
c'était pour expliquer un petit peu les
rapports entre entre un européen
occidental et oriental et puis voilà les
différences de conception il essaie de
montrer que les choses étaient comme ils
le disent les dupont et dupond c'est une
satire de la police ou ubu porte en lui
un tat n'appartiennent pas à la police
et lors non non non rien qu'on y est et
puis du produit pour la partie
logicielle ma police ont vraiment alors
2010 en doublant qu'un cycle les jumeaux
est sûre je met plein les policiers je
n'ai pas eu de grands noms et tournesol
vous moquer de la science entendu tous
les noms au contraire il est parvenu à
aller sur la lune lui avant tout il est
un peu sourit est un peu distrait mais
ça n'empêche pas d'avoir une brillante
idée de nerfs bien voulez oui j'allais
où j'allais oublier j'étais chargé lui
une commission et au four vous avez
répondu tout à l'heure c'est anne mes
neveux qui s'appelle stéphane et qui m'a
dit c'est d'abord ça lui parle et c'est
fabuleux vous rencontrer alors ça c'est
plus sérieux que la littérature est et
il m'a dit est ce que tu osera lui poser
une question j'ai dit oui il m'a dit
quel âge as tu un tas
vous avez répondu c'est un reporter de
15 ans à mais apparemment c'est quand
même le seul point qui inquiète à un
très jeune lecteur c'est cette
permanence glissa du personnage à
travers le temps est cependant
il est difficile pour un personnage
comme ça devait faire vieillir parce que
s'ils vieilli va maintenant il va avoir
un deux ans il va rencontrer les filles
se marient a pour mot ce propos j'ai lu
j'ai vu la dent dans fluxys yann une
revue assez irrespectueuse ou le un
épisode faute atteint évidemment le
scandale du peuple congolais où on
apprend que tintin qui a bien vieilli
on voit les dupont et dupond aussi
qu'ils sont des gens très chenu et il
semblerait que tu atteins effet un
enfant au congo il
non s'il est fluide glacial voilà et la
caisse compenser ça c'est le succès
voici l'enfer de la drogue on voit
tintin on voit tintin se piquer dans une
prison as toujours influent catherine
marc est toujours caché ça aussi mais ça
ne vous ça ne vous tente pas en lui en
le gardant son âge les moeurs évoluent
en ça ne vous tente pas un garçon de 15
ans aujourd'hui ils tombent amoureux il
a il a des tentations peut-être pas
aussi grand oui c'est kevin c'est est-ce
que c'est pas un problème non pas du
tout non jeu parce que je crois que la
raison en est bien simple je crois quand
j'ai commencé sa gt je sortais du
scoutisme détruit jambes et on y pense
aux arrêts et les gens de notre âge et
c'est vrai tu es
les poulets scouts à cette époque là
pour les personnes et stages les
systèmes monte tout à fait différent oui
oh quand même les chefs des nous réunit
aujourd'hui foot avec vous un oui oui
oui il a bien sûr oui bien sûr et à
cette époque là vraiment c'était tout à
fait séparé les garçons d'un côté les
filles de l'autre on le voyait comme est
très loin mais c'est une question est
est ce que le créateur n'est pas jaloux
de ses créatures je veux dire par là
c'est que bon tata il a 50 ans il est
toujours le même vous vous avez aussi 50
ans de plus vous avez un petit peu plus
de 70 ans vous ne vous êtes pas quatorze
rencontres
il n'empêche que vous avez un peu plus
de 70 et que vous vous aviez ces
créatures où elle ne vieillit pas non je
suis pas jaloux mais il est possible que
ce soit une production de moi-même qui
espérait ne pas vieillir c'est
impossible enfin c'est peut-être ça et
puis je crois réellement que ces
personnages là ne peuvent pas vieilli je
me souviens en tout cas du véritable
chagrin que j'ai eu quand j'ai eu la
mort de d'artagnan d' or tous les bidons
de bragelonne
pour moi ça aurait dû toujours resté les
trompes ce que tu es et ce que tu
mourras avec vous je crois que oui je
crois que c'est à dire qu'il n'y aura
plus de tintin on fabriquera pas de
tintin votre atelier n'aurions mais oui
mais ça c'est un groupe je crois
réellement vg d'excellents
collaborateurs ils font de très belles
choses et qu'il faut le font beaucoup
mieux que le préfet moi même mais je
crois que à la base quand même malgré ça
c'est malgré tout un travail personnel
et comme je vous le disais en commençant
tintin c'est moi le capitaine haddock
sait moins c est un autre
le ferait peut-être mieux le ferai
peut-être moins bien le ferait toute
façon une façon très différente de moi
donc je crois qu'il vaut mieux
jessica biel vous avez lu ou tapez 1
certes oui mais pas pour ses missions
autrefois vous l'avez vous avez un fils
j'ai toujours un fils qui était temps
dora sion éventail naturellement tous
les livres que l'on le htv lisait québec
je peux dire que j'ai été à partir de là
de quelques 25 30 ans j'ai été nourri
moi aussi hautain et bien entendu et
comment cela vous a paru du 1er mai
figurez vous qu'à la lumière de michelet
vive et j'ai pensé je me suis dit qu'il
y avait un côté finish les discothèques
justement un côté professeur tournesol
le le savant et où il ya dans les dents
montherlant dans l'écart d'un de
montherlant
il parle de michelet de la façon dont
michelet ce s'exprime sur les femmes
notamment
il lit ce nigaud niche l'est pour de
choses évidemment qui paraissent à un
peu ridicule ce nigaud de michelet ce
quelque chose comme dirait pas de
châteaubriant par exemple on peut aimer
ou ne pas aimer chateaubriand mais
chateaubriand ne lira jamais le négoce
ont peu dire ce nigaud
mais on peut dire également ce nigaud de
professeur tournesol
ce qui est à la fois risible et charmant
et charmant c'est ce qu'on tenait à ce
que des naïfs du savant qui est en même
temps un peu enfantin alors c'est à ça
que vous pensez en venant ici je pensais
que tournesol était une nouveau type de
michelet c'est à dire le savant qui d'un
côté et touchant de l'autre côté
ridicule mais ça va quand même mais en
même temps et encore lorsqu'on sait leur
vie sentimentale qui sûrement pas on ne
sait pas comment
très discret ce qu'elle vaut mais quel
succès à voir en angleterre je lave ou
je ne sais pas je crois que je crois
qu'il est assez grand mais je j'avoue
qu'en en ce qui me concerne la première
fois que j'ai eu contact avec tintin
c'est il ya quelques semaines quand j'ai
commencé à voir les albums assessement
vous avez lu d'eau pour l'émission c'est
ça qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous à
une lecture tout neuf et bien il y en a
qui semble terriblement rétro par
exemple la chine
je me suis donc lucas bleys aperçu oui
que c'est quand même très très vieux le
congo s'il ya un langage cru liseret
avait souhaité cette année on dirait
même 35
côté financier bongo s'est passé
colonialiste quand oui on a fait des
choses que vous n'y a pas maintenant et
ça me rappelle un peu
vous avez sûrement connu ces livres
d'enfants où il ya un capitaine bigot
rose un anglais qui est un héros de la
de l'aviation anglaise du temps la
première guerre mondiale
eh bien ces avions sont toujours les
avions de la première guerre mondiale ne
vieillissent pas et il est votre non
plus finalement est ce que est ce que
les gens sont comprennent qu'il s'agit
d'une chine d'il ya très très longtemps
je ne sais pas est ce que vous n'avez
pas est ce que vous voulez pas faire une
espèce de un tintin poste mao par
exemple non non mais je crois que les
légers refait 2,3 rim est par exemple y
avait une ligne noire ça ça se passait
en grande-bretagne gelé refait avec
d'autres avions d'autres l'autre
apparaît d'autres trains enfin de mettre
dans un décor plus typiquement
britannique
mais je crois que les lecteurs semblent
en tout cas ne pas ne pas se rendre
compte de ce ce côté rétro qui reste qui
est vrai qui est cette année on remarque
géant de bolloré fait à malraux en dise
un teint c'est moi l'interprété comment
est ce que comme chose que le général de
gaulle un certain humour
en tout cas moi je trouve que de gaulle
c'est un teint plus mille ou plus
haddock
oui mais c'était pas tellement mal euros
c'est peut-être ici dans le rôle annulé
il a produit mais il n'a pas que te fais
10 à 2 où il a dit je n'ai qu'un seul
rival c'est tintin il dit ceci à
l'international auriverde
c'est ce que malraux fait dire fait dire
en tout cas c'est ça mais vos deux
chefs-d'oeuvre sur les visas et 22
albums publiés
23 22 23 ou chicanes ont pas mal pour
moi là vraiment c'est qu'ils aient tous
lui c'est à la fois c'est le secret de
la licorne suivi du trésor de rackham le
rouge
l exotisme s'exile non plus simplement
c'est parce que d'abord on voit
apparaître le château de moulinsart et
puis on voit apparaître aussi dans ces
tournesols je prends les paris oui
évidemment on voit vraiment toute la
galerie de portraits laqué et un petit
bond edouard baer alors vous vous être
portée à grand reporter tintin la vie
que c'était un reporter est ce que vous
considérez que le grand reporter edouard
baer a des affinités avec le petit
reporter tintin non je ne crois pas
vraiment parce que on l ai dit de mon
livre que c'était leur portée en tant
que victime je crois que c'est tout à
fait vrai je m'identifie plutôt à woody
allen cas qu'atteinte 1